l'annonce n'a pas encore été
officialisée mais la nouvelle se répand
déjà auprès des Plaisirois leur mare Joë
rau a décidé de quitter ses fonctions je
comprends pas pourquoi qu' démissionne
c'est dommage c'est un bon m on l'imit
bien c'est tout il doit avoir une bonne
raison c'est peut-être parce qu'il en a
marre il est fatigué il ve prendre r pu
c'est tout chche pas comprendre qu'
raison ve plus je sais qu'il Ava de
santé je pense que
c'est je suis étonné qui n'aille pas
jusqu'au bout de son mandat c'est tout
je l'ai appris en début de semaine par
une cliente qui est allé à une réunion
voilà je me pose des questions est-ce
stratégique
est-ce pour des raisons de santé on n
sait rien
entre étonnement et questionnement la
raison de son départ reste flou contacté
par téléphone Joë réot nous a confié
vouloir préparer les prochaines
élections municipales en mars 2014 une
très bonne image on a eu des bons
contacts ensemble on a jamais souci avec
lui non non franchement rien à dire
B pour la petite enfance je trouve qu'il
a pas fait grandchose vraiment une très
bonne image il a fait une excellente
administration de la ville depuis qu'il
y est et on ne pourra que regretter son
départ moi ça fait qu'un an que que je
suis à mon compte donc j'ai pas vraiment
de rapport avec je ne connais pas
particulièrement mais j'ai pas me
plainre en tant qu'habitante de plaisir
Joséphine Berg son adjote et à la
communication est pressentie pour
reprendre le poste le maire UMP occupait
cette fonction depuis
2001 je ne connais pas cette dame mais
je pense que si c'est Monsieur Réau qui
a choisi de lui donner sa succession ça
ça doit être favorable c'est une
passation de pouvoir c'est tout c'est
pas il il passe la main à Madame Colmas
berger et il reste au conseil c'est une
élu déjà depuis son le premier mandat
donc c'est une femme qui est très bien
il il y aura aucun problème avec elle
Joë réot annoncera son départ ce jeudi
soir lors du conseil municipal de
plaisir le maire a préparé un courrier
qu'iladressera aux habitants de sa ville
pour les informer de sa décision il
répondra officiellement aux questions de
la presse dès l'approbation de sa
démission par le préfet début novembre
un conseil municipal extraordinaire
devrait se tenir le 15
novembre